how's it going guys it's ideas of Ice
and Fire and welcome to the next episode
of my podcast on this episode we're
gonna be talking about Lovecraft
and all of the Lovecraft stuff inside of
the Song of Ice and Fire today I have
brought on order of the green hand to
talk about the Lovecraft stuff with me
hi I'm Dave from the Order of the green
hand unfortunately m'lady
isn't able to join us today but uh
hopefully you guys aren't too
disappointed and you can make do with me
now everyone has been waiting for this
Lovecraft talk for a really long time
HP Lovecraft is the father of cosmic
horror and the 1920s he authored stories
which explored our fears involving the
vastness of the cosmos unraveling sanity
and the fear of alienation not just of
oneself but on a deeper level the fear
of the other of the unknown one of the
common themes of Lovecraft's work is the
obtaining of secret knowledge which
often drives a character to madness or
sends them down a path of despair and
terror this secret knowledge is often
represented by a glimpse into the hidden
realms of an eldritch abomination which
are another common theme in Lovecraft
eldritch abominations are the cosmic
deities that exist throughout
Lovecraft's work these beings have
motives that are inconceivable to a man
they appear in forms which are often
indescribable cults which are another
common theme in the story worshiped and
act as agents to these cosmic deities
another common theme in Lovecraft's work
is the theme of the tainted blood line
in Lovecraft stories it's often implied
that a character has a terrible ancestor
that they are descended
from some abomination and this often
feels them with some sense of
existential dread Georgia Martin
obviously loves HP Lovecraft he uses
like names and places all the time over
and over again and even like themes and
ideas a lot of them are very love crafty
and if you like this channel make sure
you like this video and subscribe check
me out on patreon follow me on Twitter
and Facebook and yeah so without further
ado let's get right into it first we're
gonna talk about Kadath now if you've
read the world of Ice and Fire than you
know that Kadath is a castle or city in
the gray waste and it's inspired by a
Lovecraft story well a couple of
Lovecraft stories but the one that I'm
gonna focus on here is the dream quest
of unknown Kadath now this is a crazy
trippy story written in the 1920s by
Lovecraft and it's one of my favorite
novellas so in love craft Kadath is an
ancient city it's the home of the dream
gods of Earth otherwise known as the
great ones
now Kadath exact location in the
universe is uncertain there is even
confusion over whether it exists in the
dream world or the waking world
however in Lovecraft's at the mouth of
madness it is hinted that the mountain
ranges beyond the Antarctic Plateau of
ling may hide the location of Kadath but
in the dream quest of Qaddafi Randolph
Carter finds the unknown city far north
of lean so in A Song of Ice and Fire
Qaddafi is just east of the bleeding sea
and north of the land of the shrieks
farther south are the five forts to the
southeast of Kadath Arbonne town and the
dry deep while in the northeast is a
great waste the inhabitants of Kedah
claim the city is the first and oldest
city in the world it is said that Kadath
is the site of unspeakable rites
perform'd to select the hunger of mad
gods and even the shrieks that dwell in
the land south of the city fear it so
this is the story of the dream quest for
good
for unknown Kadath so there's this guy
named Randall Carter he dreams three
times of this beautiful majestic sunset
city but each time the dream is pulled
away from him before he can get a good
look at it he prays to the dream gods
the great ones to reveal the whereabouts
of this majestic city but he receives no
answer from the gods Carter then says
that I'm just gonna go find Kadath
myself and cut out this where these gods
live and he wants to beseech them on
purpose and ask them why they've stopped
showing him the city so in a dream he
descends down 77 steps and he speaks to
two priests and these priests live on
the edge of the dream lands and they
warn Carter maybe the gods have withdrew
withdrew this vision for a reason maybe
you shouldn't go looking for this it's
dangerous but he doesn't care and he
goes on this epic quest through the
dream lands and the story ends with this
huge battle Carter summons these ghouls
from the underworld and they fight these
horned men of Ling yes link horn demand
of Ling that's another Lovecraft
reference in A Song of Ice and Fire
and after a fight he finally arrives in
Kadath and this is where the mindfuck
happens so there's no one in Kedah and
he's like what the hell and then this
Pharaoh like man walks in and he tells
Carter that the gods of Earth have seen
his dream city and they have decided to
make it their home they have abandoned
Kadath the gods walk no more in the ways
of the gods and they have become instead
denizens of the jeweled city that Carter
had glimpsed in his dreams but it is
also revealed here that this dream city
that Carter saw was nothing more than
his childhood memories of his home city
of Boston so this is the horror of
setting cosmic rage loose on yourself or
on your city this guy called ancient
deities to his hometown of Boston and
these beings are now living in Boston
he's like brought them to Boston so this
is what the Pharaoh like man says to him
it is not over unknown sees he says but
back over well-known years that der
quest must go back to the bright strange
things of infancy and the quick
sun-drenched glimpses of magic that old
scenes brought to wide young eyes for
know you that your gold and marble city
of Wonders is only the sum of what you
have seen and loved in youth these
things you saw Randolph Carter when your
nurse verse willed you out into the
springtime and they will be the last
things you will ever see with eyes of
memory and love so this guy this Pharaoh
like man reveals himself to be none
other than Naya arleth attempt the
hunter of the dark the emissary of the
outer God's who dwells within a
blackness of space nile at the tap is
worshipped by the Church of the starry
wisdom which is also mentioned in A Song
of Ice and Fire according to the world
of Ice and Fire the bloodstone Emperor
start at the Church of the story wisdom
so at this point Randolph Carter is sent
on the back of a great bird to the
sunset city but Carter realizes that
he's being tricked and gnarley' the tip
is actually sending him to the court of
as atha is an arrow that attempts father
at the center of the universe he
realizes that he's in a dream Carter
does and he realizes that I can just
jump from this bird so he jumps from the
bird he wakes up in his bed finds
himself still in Boston and the story
ends with gnarley' thought at being like
oh man I lost and he caused that he
calls the dream God's out of Boston and
back into Qaddafi so that is the trippy
crazy story of the dream quest for
unknown Kadath and it involves all this
stuff that Georgia Martin uses NarL at
the temp who is worshipped by the Church
of the starry wisdom which is in A Song
of Ice and Fire Kadath which is in the
bleeding sea which is not in the
bleeding sea but near the bleeding sea
and A Song of Ice and Fire so there's a
lot of references here a really
important thing to be said here also I
think is that the sunset city really
represents Randolph Carter's memories of
Boston
the gods might not have actually gone to
the real Boston depending on how you
interpret the story but instead to an
idealized utopian version that he built
in his mind a city so beautiful that the
gods of Earth abandoned their post to
live there instead but you can certainly
I think still interpret it in a more
literal way as well here well I think
that it's a kind of I guess you could
say ironic and like we've said right
before we got started I was like this
has to be one of the only semi happy
endings in any of Lovecraft stories the
fact that the guy actually defeated
nayara loud tap instead of like going
completely insane which I'm probably
sure that he's probably a little crazy
now from his experience but not nearly
to the the same extent that per say
Robert Blake I want to say the main
character's name was in the Haunter of
the dark who died with the look of
cosmic horror basically on his face
that's what happens as layer into the
abyss and you don't want to look into
that abyss it seems like there's a lot
of parallels in these stories and one of
the other real things that I just wanted
to bring up sort of was the fact that
Niall a toe tap it is kind of guy has
like a million forms
he's got the dweller in the darkness the
dark one the black demon the dark demon
the crawling mist but the one that
really grabs most of my attention is the
fact that he's known as the faceless god
yes and that seems to almost give him
the direct tie the most direct tie to
our story besides the fact that there's
a church of the starry wisdom
and in kind of the way in a similar
fashion the way that Nayar latter tip is
the basically the one in only
Lovecraftian God or whatever you would
call it that regularly interacts with
humanity
yeah the faceless men literally changed
their faces and go all over the place
and are interacting directly with
humanity which seems like it's an
interesting parallel to say the least
yeah and the thing about Nyarlathotep or
however we're gonna pronounce it there's
a couple of different ways I guess is
that he likes to sow chaos he's also
called something like the Lord of Chaos
or something like that I believe or the
crawling Cates I think it's the crawling
chaos yes : chaos the crawling chaos so
he he walks the earth he lives amongst
men often often times he can take any
form really and he creates chaos so just
think about the ways that chaos is
represented in A Song of Ice and Fire I
think that one character that I think
represents narrow the tap a little bit
could be Littlefinger potentially
because he's all about chaos I really
like that speech that he gives in season
3 of the television show this isn't in
the book but it's kind of representative
of the same thing he says chaos is a
ladder it's like you can climb that
ladder I don't think it's a coincidence
either that his family hails from
Braavos the home of of men the faceless
men seems to me that there might be some
sort of at the very least loose
connection so the Church of the starry
wisdom is also mentioned in A Song of
Ice and Fire
as I said earlier and in Lovecraft they
worship nigh arleth attempt who is known
as the hunter of the dark and in a Song
of Ice and Fire the Church of the
started wisdom is this cult that's said
to be still at still active even in
modern a song of ice and fire times and
it was started by the bloodstone Emperor
supposedly
to the world of ice and fire according
to some myths so you have to wonder in
what ways are this cult is this cult
active still you have to wonder are they
still manipulating things behind the
scenes are they influencing characters
behind the scenes I think they are I
think there's evidence to suggest that
Marwan the mage could be related to the
Church of the story wisdom and also
potentially quake as well I think the
Church of the story wisdom could very
well be axed a guy in the center of the
heart of darkness and that Quaithe could
be coming from that place because
Daenerys sees her in the when she's
dying when Daenerys is almost dying and
she's getting the visions at the end of
the fifth book Quast her mask is made of
starlight it's I mean I mean there's
there's a lot of hints she hears the
whisperings of the stars starry wisdom
so it makes a lot of sense I would have
to agree with you there the other thing
that I was thinking about with the
Church of the starry wisdom is uh the
idea of making sacrifices and what
you're making sacrifices for is like
otherworldly knowledge humans thirst for
knowledge and understanding it seems
like that is the type of thing if they
that these Lovecraftian gods they very
much use that against them like in the
story where you were just reading the
guy who thought the guy really wanted to
get to this place and nayer latter tap
almost tricked him into going someplace
else because he thought that he would
hmm because he thought that he was going
to get the answers that he seat there
and it's similar to almost makes you
think a little bit of like the way that
the children of the forest used the
weirwood trees they make seemingly a lot
of sacrifices to it to obtain knowledge
from the trees or in the church of the
started wisdom in the story as like they
were doing the people from the town in
the hunter in the dark were disappearing
seemingly they were being sacrificed so
nyle an attempt would give the cultists
otherworldly knowledge and that seems to
be like a common theme or if you
extrapolate that out to other things a
lot of these darker deities and the
stories are in the story they require
sacrifice which could be the black goat
of qohor which I guess we haven't really
gotten there yet but that's the jamuna
Groth or however you say it I was like
that requires blood blood sacrifice
seemingly around the time of a new
because that is the only time that the
shouldna growth can be summoned and what
they seem to be summoning the ship no
growth for is otherworldly knowledge I'm
guessing as that they don't really give
you a lot of information about what
they're doing over there in qohor other
than they have this massive blood
sacrifice table thing that the blood
flows to the black goat somehow and then
they can be summoned and will give them
what they were seeking there see when I
hear all the stories about qohor it just
makes me realize that all these things
are connected even more because co hora
is like the modern of Illyria they're
like the closest thing to Valyria now
they can remake Valyrian steel they have
all this magical knowledge that nobody
else has anywhere in the world and the
Valyrians according to the world of Ice
and Fire according to a myth that
Georgia Martin himself brings up the
Valyrians got their power got their
magic and knowledge from
people of the shadow in a shy so it all
continuously connects it's it's like
it's like the shadow in a shy Valyria
qohor it all goes and all these
Lovecraftian references are scattered in
between so let's talk about Cthulhu for
a little bit I guess uh one more thing
that I wanted to bring up and this is
the thing that I forgot that I wanted to
say about the Church of the starry
wisdom okay is their presence in port
cities only that seems in some way shape
or form significant and could be an
interesting tie in to where you just
wanted to go with Cthulhu because
obviously Cthulhu is from the deep and
ports are humans access to the deep kind
of if you will that makes a lot of thin
fill with so maybe the Church of the
starry wisdom is connected to the deep
ones as well the squishers which totally
exists in the Song of Ice and Fire by
the way they seem like they have to
someplace or may or may be the squishers
could even be what those ambitious
sailors who have sailed far enough north
to have seen these very strange black
and white
Merlin's they call the Merlin's or
mermaids uh that drag Souls down to the
deep yeah I have theorized that they're
all the same thing that these legends of
the squishers and the Marling's they all
come from the deep ones
I think they built a lot of this oily
stone I think they probably built the
sea stone chair I think they built the
idol over on toad Isle that's made of
that greasy black stone where the fish
people worship it people that letter
clearly like humanoid fish people
because the deep ones have bread with
them and that's totally a thing in
Lovecraft as well a deep once breeding
with humans and creating hybrid deep one
human creatures kind of reminds you of
the almost like the brindled men of
authorial as well which are like
part human and part boar or something to
that effect and I was like these part
human things that seem to exist
throughout this story it seems like it's
a very Lovecraftian idea cuz obviously
that doesn't come from from our world
and uh yeah it almost makes you think of
the bloodstone Emperor marrying a tiger
woman whatever that is there's never
been able to find an actual definition
of what that is that is that isn't an
interesting one but I was thinking that
it was probably like maybe a woman from
Ling perhaps
and speaking of Ling - I know that in
that story I just read it mentions Ling
as well and it talks about the horned
man of Ling and like the horned men or a
thing that George or Martin does as well
that's totally a George or Martin thing
so it's another thing that's borrowed so
you have to wonder how Ling fits in as
well that whole Far Far East area he has
maintained such an incredible like aura
of mystery about it we have so little
information and it's almost I'm gonna
say for lack of a better word irritating
to me that that these maesters have no
knowledge from that area it's like how
hard would it be for you guys to send
some dudes over there and find out
what's going on and then have them
report back
is it a couple unless there is something
that's aware that's like blocking the
knowledge from leaving the place I mean
that that I don't know I mean if we're
gonna get really in there let's say like
a Lovecraftian deity exists in the isang
of Ice and Fire universe maybe it
wouldn't people necessarily wouldn't
want people necessarily to know about it
okay so it by Stephen King it's a very
Lovecraftian story it's like straight
out of Lovecraft right so it is like an
entity that came to earth so that it
could feed off of human energy right off
of human fear basically off of human
imagination
and it came there millions of years
before humans got there because it knew
that one day they would be there but it
created it created a place in its own
image it's killing pin this town called
Derry and like mess stuff stuff happens
in this town but like no one
it never gets out no one ever knows
about it so in the book you realized
that this entity this deity it is
keeping it from leaving it's keeping the
information from going out because
really messed-up stuff has happened in
this town that if it happened anywhere
else
it'll be like all over the news and
stuff but you realize that this being is
making people forget and just making
people not think about it like these
kids grow up and they leave the town and
they forget they forget their childhoods
they just don't think about it so that's
kind of how a Lovecraftian deity
operates it doesn't necessarily want you
anyone to know it wants to keep
receiving it's sacrifice in peace
without it getting out but that's kind
of tinfoil II I'm not necessarily
suggesting that an actual Lovecraftian
deity exists in the Song of Ice and Fire
but that that is the way it would work
theoretically you know what that just
made me think of when you said that it
made me think of norvos and how any
person you can go to norville's and you
can hang out in the town but if you
wander into their temple you never come
out alive
they will not let an outsider who is not
an initiate of their religion there see
what happens inside that temple and live
to tell about it
I was like that just struck a chord in
my mind when you were just saying that I
was like that sounds awfully norvo she
yeah it's like they have a secret that
cannot get out necessarily and who knows
what it is they could be hiding some
dark god of incredible power because I
did this theory video one time and it
was about it was my kind of crazy take
on the great Empire of the dawn over an
et and I was I was thinking about how
the world of Ice and Fire describes the
the first emperor that ruled for the
emperor of the dawn that ruled for
10,000 years he ascended into the stars
when he died and it was after that that
the Empire of the dawn fell apart and
became gradually less and less
prosperous and we hear about the
bloodstone Emperor who worshipped a
stone that fell out of the sky this is a
very Lovecraftian idea like I think
about maybe the great emperor of the
dawn not actually being a human and
actually being a deity from the sky and
when he left other entities might have
saw the vacancy that this powerful
entity left behind and swarmed the earth
essentially they saw this richness to
feed off of they saw and look at what
the bloodstone Emperor did he he
sacrificed to all these like crazy
messed up gods for like who knows what
and they gave him this tiger woman as a
bride who knows what she was and we do
know that the Valerians
they did play with human-animal hybrids
that's in the world of Ice and Fire I
believe so that's mentioned there as
well I'm not really sure what whether
that was them or the ghiscari it's on
that really creepy Island tuff ago sews
gogo sews is what it's called and in
like the third or fourth Valyrian and
ghiscari wore the Valyrians took that
place and turned it into a prison for
all intents and purposes but it's not
exactly clear as to which one of them
whether it be the ghiscari or them
started this weird practice of kind of
like for lack of a better word Mendelian
experimentation yeah I put my money on
the Valyrians because they did a lot of
messed-up stuff it would seem it seems
like I can't really tell I was like cuz
the ghiscari are seem to be at the very
least less apologetic about doing like
messed up stuff like their culture I
mean the example I like to use a lot of
the time is down at their fighting pits
when they reopened the Colosseum's there
or whatever
one day they like smothered a kid in are
three little boys like eight-year-olds
won't in like blood fish guts and honey
or something like that and then made
bets on which one a bear would kill
first I was like they the lack of
respect I guess you could say for the
value of human life seems to be like
ingrained in their culture those who are
I guess you could say quote-unquote less
than you are not even human
and are your
basically like your playthings the
things that you can do experiments on
and yeah I think we've seen a lot more
of the cruelty of the ghiscari firsthand
but we do know that the Valerians
historically treated their slaves
horribly like the minds of the 14 flames
was like not not a good place to be like
I mean the faceless men offered them the
gift of death okay that's where it all
started in those [ __ ] up minds so I
mean the Valerians could have been just
as cruel and we know that all of their
magic was rooted in fire and blood I
mean whose blood are they using they're
not probably not using noble blood
they're most likely using the blood of
their slaves that could be but it also
seems like the more important the
person's blood is the more powerful the
sorcery is like that does seem so if
you're going for something truly epic it
seems like you would have had to have
used for lack of a better word of noble
Valyrians blood to perform it I wonder
about Kings blood a lot it's likely
because I what I wonder how far it
actually how far does it go really I was
like I actually feel like I might have
seen you say this in one of your videos
a really long time ago like so like go
over to a rock and declare myself a king
is my blood magic now yeah yeah exactly
like like if I get like 15 people to
come up around me and say that I'm king
is my blood suddenly more potent than
the next guy over there I mean what what
what does that mean how far does it
actually go and then how far down the
blood line can you continue until the
blood of the king is too far diluted I
mean cuz like Mill Sanders trying to
sacrifice Hedrick storm because his
father is Robert Baratheon but would
Adric storm son still have the same
magical potential see this is an idea
that we can't while back because it must
have been well over a year ago when we
did there's power in King's blood I
think we called the video and
we kind of agreed with you with your
statement that I just said a minute ago
like calling yourself a king doesn't
seem to have any tangible makes your
blood stronger aspect to it so then we
were looking at especially in the case
of Eid ryx storm when she said he has
King's blood most of the time it its ki
ng s ' but when she when she speaks of
it every other time with the exception
of him with him or her ki ng apostrophe
s that's how she normally says it with
him she pluralized it as in Kings blood
on both sides of his family
multiple Kings blood which made us think
that it's because he had Garth greenhand
blood on both sides of his because the
broth Ian's married the Girondins who
are rumored at the very least to have
the durán gods wave was rumored to have
been one of our related to Garth in some
way shape or form and Garth seems like
he was a God of some sort
[Music]
actually in one of the little asides
that George put into the world of ice
and fire he were to him straight up as a
god
it was just what type of God he was
whether he was bright and sunshiny God
or a little bit of a darker deity but it
made us think that Kings blood is
actually you having God's blood like
more like the line of like a Hercules or
something like that were you are a
descendant of some sort of demigod from
thousands and thousands of years ago and
if you have that blood in you which a
lot of people would and it would be how
potent your God's blood is that would
have the most effect on whether or not
the blood magic is stronger or weaker
I'm not really sure if I did a good job
of explaining it but that was kind of
like the basic premise that we came up
and it was because of the Diedrich storm
in the fact that she pluralized his gods
earth Kings blood we were talking about
the Church of the started wisdom and you
brought up them only being in important
cities and we were gonna try and tie
that into the Cthulhu thing because
maybe that is a connection that we have
there maybe they commune with the
drowned God as well or what the Ironborn
think is the drowned God maybe this
sorry wisdom have a better idea of what
this really is and it seems to I mean we
know the religion of the drowned God is
is based off of the worship of Cthulhu
what his dead may never die it's just a
play on a Lovecraftian saying that is
not dead which can eternal lie and with
strange Aeons even death may die so
Cthulhu is very much so tied into the
religion of the drowned guy and even
says that they'll join their God in his
watery halls Cthulhu lives in an
underground city called relay so I think
that what's really interesting to me is
the fact that he's dreaming and they're
waiting for him to awake
um that really really intrigues me
because of some of the ancient will say
myths or legends from the story about
awakening Giants or gods or something
with things like there's a reference
that we're going to be talking about in
our upcoming what woke the others video
about the hammer of the waters awoke
giants in the earth I was like they just
throw that random line into it same with
the Horn of Joramun exactly that was
actually something else that we brought
up in that video that we're almost done
recording now and it kind of really it
it strikes me it in the same way and and
Cthulhu is allegedly hundreds of meters
tall he's huge he's huge I was like and
it seems like
it reminds me oh that's what I was gonna
say of the old nan legend that she told
both John and Aria both of them recall
it Aria recalls it I believe when she's
at Harrenhal and it made her think of
old Nan's stories about some giant who
lives in a palace that is of a magnitude
that like humans can't even imagine and
there's no there's no evidence anywhere
above the water that such a place exists
there's never been like a ruin of some
sort discovered by somebody that is of
that magnitude which makes me think that
what John thinks of and what when he
first sees one of the Giants north of
the wall and what Aria thinks of when
she's looking at harrenhal are
potentially the Drowned gods watery
halls and that's what old man was
actually speaking of it makes a lot of
sense if you just put it under water
yeah and the other thing about it being
of a magnitude that a human can't
imagine like Lovecraft loves to say you
can't imagine this because he like in
the story called Cthulhu where you were
actually there these men that actually
stand on relay there are all these
strange angles that shouldn't exists in
like shapes and like terms that don't
make any sense right so it's kind of
like who knows how big it really is
because you you like the human mind
can't even really like conceptualize and
then I got me thinking that it might not
be a coincidence that a worshipper of
the drowned God built by far the largest
castle in the known world kind of
harrenhal to a magnitude that Aria said
like Aaron can't even compare Winterfell
which is huge to it she's like they're
not even in the same ballpark the
magnitude of the size of all this stuff
and it kind of made me think that Harun
was potentially like building
in above-ground relay if you will yeah
and the cool thing about Cthulhu - is
that he's not just dreaming he's also
dead he's dead dreaming he's dead and
alive at the same time he's like in some
kind of weird between and we don't know
why he is dead and alive and imprisoned
inside of this castle we don't know why
like we don't know who did it or why is
there but what we do know is that he
will return and that is that it's also a
bit of the cosmic horror that Lovecraft
is playing with because it's like when
he returns there's nothing that humans
can do to stand against him and so like
when it happens it's it happens so is
there some entity in A Song of Ice and
Fire just bubbling beneath the surface
waiting for its time to rise I mean
there is euron greyjoy I mean in the
Forsaken chapter we do see him with a
literal Cthulhu face on the Iron Throne
with all the other gods and paled upon
it and he's asking his brother the damp
Harrow to worship Him he's saying I am
your God he definitely has some kind of
god complex so I did without a doubt
Georgia or Martin is playing with the
idea of the Cthulhu Mythos and the rise
in God
so that's SERP that's most certainly
what's happening here he literally has a
Cthulhu head literally that was
something you're on is the rise in God
that was something else that I was
thinking about is the fact that
cthulhu's head looks like for all
intents and purposes a massive Kraken
as if that doesn't seem like it's a
coincidence that the Greyjoy's who rule
the Iron Islands the place that worships
the drowned God their symbol or on their
banners is a massive Kraken which almost
would indicate that it's the head of
Cthulhu I mean without a doubt it's it's
it's I think it's very on the surface
actually George R Martin I think did
that purposely because he knows what
kethu that looks like he knows that this
is the deal and the people that pick up
on it pick up on it and then the people
that don't pick up on it don't pick up
on it because I've listened to George R
Martin speak before about
like him like putting all these little
subtle things in here and not really
expecting anyone to guess it but he
didn't anticipate the Internet he can
anticipate like nerds like coming
together and researching all this stuff
and figuring it out so maybe he put like
these iTunes IDs in here and he thought
they'd be like more subtle because not
everyone's read Lovecraft but now
Lovecraft is like going through this
like huge boom it's like very popular at
the moment but you know back then it
wasn't like like it is like now it's
like certainly seem like an uprising in
the modern times
so maybe george RR martin didn't think
these things would be so on the surface
but yeah you can clearly see that
connection there the way that we like to
think of George's writing style is he
overwhelms you with detail so he can
hide the truth of things right there in
plain sight
that's brilliant yeah definitely
everything is so detailed so you wonder
like what is supposed to be like
actually significant right it's because
everything is detailed exactly in
somewhere what we've noticed is
sometimes in in such slightly oddly
phrased dialogue or somewhere amidst an
incredible paragraph of detail they'll
be like something that almost seems a
little bit out of place but he just
buried it in the middle of a paragraph
that's overwhelming your senses do you
know what my favorite example of
something like that is the millah
saundra POV chapter when she's talking
about glamouring and she's like she's
like a shield a dress a bag of finger
bones and she just throws that in like
what you're like who why would you
squeeze why would you say that whose
glamoured like davos like if I miss her
exactly glamour does it did you find his
finger bones somehow and you're using
them yes it makes you rethink maybe even
the Davos chapters like like or is it
really devastating like reading here I
don't know because he doesn't have them
apparently in those chapters so and it's
really confusing because he titles the
chapters as whoever the person's
pretending to be like mm-hm
Sansa Sansa's chapters are Elaine Elaine
yeah the cat of the canals yeah I mean
yeah so it's like and he really plays
this slightly like I guess I'll call it
a game it's not really a game with
identities in people losing their
identities like Sansa is becoming is
losing her son's identity and becoming
Elaine in at first she's still a Sansa
chapter and then eventually she's not
anymore and it's and now she's Elaine or
like an aria is Aria when she gets there
when she gets to the house of black and
white and they take her identity from
her I was like they're kind of there's a
similar thing going on with bran with
what the three-eyed crow is doing to
bran in his dreams early on I was like
in the way that they bind you to them
it's borderline like brainwashing creepy
I believe we did it in our video we put
out the slide up were Sansa's looking
all innocent and she's like Littlefinger
you're my only friend and it's like bran
is looking at the three-eyed crow and
he's like thinking the same thinking the
exact same thing you're my only friend
and it's like in he's desperate he's
alone he's scared he's freshly crippled
his family's dying and the crow is all
he has and he's doing whatever the crow
tells him to do yeah there's not enough
questioning of what is going on there
and I say it all the time I know some
people think the thread crow is good he
could very well be good but I don't
think so I think there's something fishy
I think he's a liar and but you
mentioned losing identity speaking or
speaking of like losing yourself that's
a very love crafty and idea too
he is I think we some one of us said
earlier on this podcast
don't stare into the Biss because the
abyss stares back and you can lose
yourself in the abyss and this happens
over and over in Lovecraft stores people
are exposed to cosmic madness like the
truth and they cannot handle it and it
makes them go insane and that is that's
something that I think has happened in
the Song of Ice and Fire and I think my
best example of that
is Patch face now the religion of the
drowned God they drown you well they
they drown you but then they resuscitate
you like so you like die and come back
and it's like you're closer to the
drowned God a patch face he's unlike
anyone else because he's actually
drowned he was washed away for three
days and then they found his body he was
dead when Johnny found him but then he
woke up he was given to the drowned God
and brought back and he completely lost
his mind but at the same time he is he's
giving prophecies and speaking truths
but he's mad at the same time he's
deranged but he's still speaking truth
so it's very interesting he's become
like the mouthpiece almost for a god and
who knows to what end
but patch faces is an example of someone
that's stared into cosmic madness and
been completely broken by it kill him I
go people ask us about patch haesol
probably a hundreds of times people have
asked is about patch face in my opinion
is a Stannis should have killed him a
long time ago I was like I'm convinced
that he's going to do something
absolutely gross gruesomely terrible
what and why is Melissa Andra seeing him
with blood around his lips why is she so
afraid of him more importantly why do
you have this grown creepy deranged man
following your daughter around and being
alone with your daughter that is like so
not cool Stannis I don't know what's
wrong with you my guy this is like not
enough it's not okay something makes me
think that it's like the one ever so
slightly sentimental thing that he has
done it's the thing it's the last gift
that his father gave him and he can't
let it go because it's the last thing
that it's like his last memory of his
parents yeah because and pates was the
only survivor of the shipwreck and
shipbreaker bay
you want to know something else that's
really really interesting about the
bloody mouth and the is that is actually
strikingly similar to one of Nayer Leto
Tepes names the god of the bloody tongue
or just simply the bloody tongue it made
me think of it when you're just talking
about the Mel Saunders visions of him
with the bloody mouth or the bloody
tongue yeah and it kind of also draws a
striking a striking resemblance to
this'll fit so yes she put out her
tongue when she bit out her tongue when
their mirror was trying to take her body
maybe when you were just saying that I
was like those two no Sandra's vision
and what this'll actually did
it also kind of reminds you almost of
the way every person describes a
weirwoods face looking so are you
suggesting that maybe like patch faces
being possessed and then he'll reject
the possession and bite out his own
tongue like this'll did that would be
quite I hadn't thought exactly of that
but that is what played out in the very
mere prologue where she rejected she
fought him off and rejected him and
fought so hard that she bit out her own
tongue which I would definitely do
because you you hear what it's let you
get a glimpse of what it's like through
Hodor
like Brandon says Hodor is like like
cuddled and like cuddled in his own
consciousness in a corner of his own
mind terrified every time bran possesses
possesses his consciousness and like it
was called an abomination for a reason
like to take another person's freewill
away is an abomination so it's like you
probably be better off dead than having
some other entity possessing your mind
and that also makes you wonder about
what's going on with the others is there
a part of each dead person that still
lingers in that mind or have they
completely gone at that point so are you
talking about the white whites yes is
there a part of that person that still
is there or it seems to because if you
go back to the scene with oath or mm-hmm
he marched straight up the stairs and
went after Mormont like he knew exactly
where it was true and I believe that
OSHA was Justin I think this is only in
a television show when OSHA tells the
story about her guy coming home and like
trying to get her that's yeah that's
only in the television show but it does
it does kind of match what goes down in
the first book with the white in the
and more monsters with although are
seeming to know where he was going and
if that means anything I don't usually
place a lot of stock in what the show
does yeah
but if if OSHA is husband knowing where
lived and coming for her kind of seems
to parallel what Oh Thor's not internal
knowledge of Castle black knowing where
to go get the Lord Commander yeah it
would seem that I like to think that
maybe there is like a kernel of
something left because it then it makes
what the White Walkers do in like a step
even worse because if there's a part of
that person that's still imprisoned
within that consciousness that's that's
horrible I mean that's like that's
that's an abomination everything in the
book so far has shown us that this is a
horrible horrible thing it does really
feel horrible taking possession it's
kind of like I've been trying to
think about like what the others bring
like if the others were to be successful
what they would bring is a world it's
like bringing like a Greek mythology
style underworld to the world of the
living everyone is dead but still and
serving them like they would have with
Hades or something I was like you know
everybody eventually in Greek mythology
makes their way to Hades and you live
out eternity in service to Hades I was
like if the White Walkers or the others
were to actually extinguish all life and
raise every single living creature that
would be an entire world that would more
closely resemble like a Greek mythology
underworld
of darkness and death which kind of is
in line with what Melisandre says she's
trying to stop from happening I mean
that would be the world if the White
Walkers won it will just be the dead I
guess unless unless they had no further
use for them and all the dead bodies
just drop dead and it was just a frozen
world where these ice creatures lived I
don't know because it seems like the
dead bodies are just more like a tool to
defeat the other humans right it's like
they're not really part of the white
Walker culture they're just kind of like
the robots they're essentially just
robots so or minions I guess you would
call them so let's talk about dreams a
little bit because an ancient God
sending a dream too feeble mortal is
totally in love crafty and thing this
happens in the Call of Cthulhu like when
before Cthulhu is waking up all these
people are going mad and having all
these dreams and seeing all the same
things and it's like driving people mad
and like giving them like [ __ ] fevers in
the middle of the night and stuff like
that and stuff like that happens in the
Song of Ice and Fire people get all
sorts of weird dreams bran probably
number one example
gets dreams from quote-unquote the
three-eyed crow
Daenerys gets all sorts of weird dreams
that just are totally like nuts and have
all this knowledge and truth so she's
getting dreams from an outward place
I think it's Quaithe you can watch a lot
of my videos to figure out some of my
thoughts on that and then there's plenty
of other characters to get dreams like
Jon Snow what his dreams and the crypts
mean Jaime Lannister has some
interesting dreams as well he sees a
woman that could potentially be his
mother of Joanna Lannister and then that
tells him that Tywin is not his father
too by the way I do recall that dream
I've always thought that was weird
because I didn't know because a lot of
like prophetic dreams are more se
symbolic than literal I was like is she
telling him that Tywin is literally not
his father or that he's not really like
his father's son in that he's very
extraordinarily different from his
father in the dream it basically plays
out just like any time that quaithe
shows up to Daenerys it's like he's like
am I dreaming and she's like you're not
dreaming I'm pretty sure this is it
seems like if you read it just on the
surface it's Jamie's mother with a glass
candle coming to him to give him some
sort of message he says can I forget
someone I never knew the words caught in
his throat he did not he did know her
but it had been so long who could it be
he did know her but it had been so long
and then she says will you forget your
own Lord father - I wonder if you ever
knew him truly what does that mean what
is she trying to say is she talking
about Tywin or are she talking about
someone else
her eyes were green her hair spun gold
he could not tell how old she was 15 he
thought or 50 he could never abide at
that was the thing he hated most so it
also sounds like she could be talking
about Tywin here too because it sounds
like she says he could never abide being
laughed at that certainly sounds to me
like the lickspittles and Aerys Court
mocking him to gain Eris's favor yes it
could be viewed that way as well and
then he says who are you and he says he
had to hear her say it the question is
who are you and then he says this is a
dream and she says is it she smiled
sadly count your hands child one hand he
has one hand and in the thing is in his
dreams he always has two hands but here
he sees his stump so it's not a dream
and then she says we all dreamed of
things we cannot have Tywin dreamed that
his son would be a great Knight that his
daughter would be a queen he dreamed
they would be so strong and brave and
beautiful that no
one would ever laugh at them I am a
knight he told her and Cersei is a queen
a tear rolled down her cheek the woman
raised her hood again and turned back
and turned her back on him Jaime called
after her but already she was moving
away her skirt whispering lullabies as
it brushed across the floor don't leave
me he wanted to call but of course she'd
left long ago he woke in darkness
shivering so obviously that is his
mother like is there any doubt that that
is his mother that he see it seems like
it absolutely has to be his mother she
has all the stereotypical lannister
looks I feel like George Martin is also
riding this in a way where you think
that it's Tywin he could never abide
being laughed at and all that stuff but
then she also says that he dreamed that
his daughter would be queen and his son
a great Knight and we don't get to have
our dreams come true and Jaime protests
and he says I am a knight Cersei is
Queen well I guess his dreams would have
came true if you two are in fact his
children which they very well may not be
Cersei and Jaime could very well be the
children of the Mad King Aerys and I put
this theory above the Tyrion being a
Targaryen theory I think that it's more
likely that it would be Cersei and Jaime
and the whole exchange plays out exactly
like a Denarius exchange between her and
Quaithe it's like the exact same type of
thing she says all this cryptic stuff
like she's like am I dreaming and she's
like is it a dream like that that's
exactly like quite showing up on top of
the pyramid or in the ship on the way a
stupor it doesn't it always seemed like
these visions that people have the thing
or the being if you will that's in the
vision is borderline mocking them yeah
it's like it's like if they never the
three-eyed crow mocks Brand
mm-hmm quaithe or whoever equate mocks
Danny almost or talks toward a mocking
fashion
yeah cousin ears just like speak clearly
why are you talking in circles and she's
just like dadadada it had to go for if
you must go west and your guards
wouldn't even see me if they came up
here and all this stuff so it is kind of
mocking yeah I was like they're never
nice Sookie just give me an answer
please yeah so the question is like all
these people that are showing up to
everyone are they really who they are
even appearing ass
or her are they something else they say
the same question goes for what
Melisandre sees in her flames is it our
issue really getting visions from her
God or allure or is it something else
some other force or entity or power
because love crafty and gods like to
pretend to they like to pretend to be
other things things that are
recognizable but really at some
unspeakable horror that's come to
consume your soul right and it kind of
makes me think of Melisandre saying that
dreams are the whisperings of the other
absolutely in in a Lovecraft universe
you have every reason to fear dreams
because dreams are the gate to the outer
world like the the other dimensions of
consciousness in reality where some of
these more powerful entities live and
like there's so much more stuff that
lives in the dream world that lives in
like the waking world it's nuts
I'll just go ahead I wasn't saying all
of these Lovecraftian beings have the
ability to haunt your dreams in the the
short story the Haunter of the dark once
Robert Blake or bloke or whatever the
main character's name was once he gazed
into the shining trapezoid Rijn the
people who lived close to the church
started complaining that's something
some dark being was haunting their
dreams
and bran refers to the three-eyed crow
as something that is haunting his dreams
quaithe seems to be somewhat haunting
Danny's dreams absolutely without a
doubt because I am under the impression
that it was quite sending those or at
least the same entity that's appearing
to be Cueva sending those visions to
Daenerys in book 1 those dreams I think
it was quite all along because every
point every time that she looked dreams
after that she actually see his quays
face but then before Quaithe had
actually introduced herself she didn't
see anyone she just heard a voice the
icy breath on the back of her neck
saying wake the dragon wake the dragon
she just heard it was more like subtle
but she didn't actually see a face but I
think it was quite manipulating her from
that very point and those dreams are
very much
torturous like she's being haunted and
she's seeing like she's seeing a lot of
horrible [ __ ] in a lot of cases you know
the last one that she has is the only
one that I felt was a was slightly
different than the others the other one
was like she kept getting waking a
dragon that was covered in her blood and
this that and the other thing and then
she thought that she saw her actually
that might be the last one where she
thought that she saw Rhaegar but it was
her I was like but there was a point in
the middle of the dream that
was incredibly interesting to us it's
the part where she's running down low
towards the red door except in this
portion of the dream there are what she
called Kings on either side of her
holding white swords that kind of really
reminded me of dawn except they seem to
be actual flame swords as opposed to
just dawn which seems like it's call
most like a solid flame sword and in
this particular portion of the dream
the eyes that the people all had silver
and gold hair which leads you to believe
that these are Valyrian 's and at first
it makes you think that they were old
Targaryen Kings except when they tell
you the eye colors of the people they
were opal and amethyst tourmaline and
Jade those are names of the Bloods of
the gemstone Emperor's from the great
Empire of the dawn and that's kind of
what spawned our idea originally that
the Valyrian czar in some way shape or
form
[Music]
descendants of them and in particular we
think the amethyst Empress because if
the people seem to be named after their
eye color if she's the amethyst Empress
she would have had purple eyes whereas
the Jade ones would have green eyes or
tourmaline I don't know a color all of
them are but amethyst would be the
purple eyed one that was the blood
portrayal and it kind of gave us the
idea that because all of these gemstone
Emperor's and empresses all seem to have
lived for entirely too long
us that she might have had a pretty
decent-sized family that escaped when
the bloodstone Emperor usurped her you
served her yeah so that makes a lot of
sense because we don't know how long
they're lives where we know they got
progressively shorter after the death of
or I should say after the ascension of
the great emperor yeah he looked ruled
apparently for like ten thousand years
and then yeah I want to say the Pearl
Emperor was the one after him and he
ruled for like a thousand or maybe a
little bit more years and then each one
got a little bit shorter a little bit
shorter until it was only like a couple
hundred years than a hundred years and
then it was like more immortal yeah it's
very biblical actually because if
anyone's familiar with the Bible you
know that people use silly according to
the Bible people used to live a long
time for example Noah was around 600
when he built the ark so yeah so like
that's like a biblical idea kind of like
we used to live long well then I guess
his more sin into the world maybe we got
progressively shorter and shorter lives
or kind of the way that we were thinking
of it is they were becoming more and
more human as they were as each
generation instead of because like the
first guy was the son of two gods and
then his offspring were likely half God
and then quarter God eighth God 16:30
second I was
again as the potent booth and as the
potency of like your God blood
diminished from more and more
generations of interbreeding or whatever
you want to call it with humans I was
like they became more and more humid so
would it be this ancient God blood that
made the Valyrians you know vessels of
magic because there's there seems to be
something inherently about them that's a
little bit more magical I mean you've
got Danny's the dreamer who was getting
visions but then again those visions
could have been sent from somewhere I've
speculated that they came out of the
shadow that whoever in the shadow gave
the Valyrians the magic wore on the
targaryen to ditch Valyria or whatever
but yeah there there is some indication
that the Valerians have certain
properties that are beyond normal
mortals one more way that I want to
throw in that A Song of Ice and Fire is
similar to Lovecraft's work is there's
all these cults that are working to
various different means and we don't
actually know why why them are doing all
these things it was the house black and
white there's churches starry wisdom are
the people in qohor there are the green
seers to an extent I mean you could
definitely call them occult a lot of
what they do seems to be like
ritualistic religious in nature a lot of
the stuff that's going on in that cave
well Cthulhu does have an enemy and his
enemy is Hester the unspeakable one and
we know that Hester the unspeakable and
is actually the mate of cheb McGrath the
Black Goat of the woods with a thousand
young who in a saga of ice and fire
apparently lives in kejoro's worship and
is worshipped by the people there so
should negra is mate - the enemy of
Cthulhu so I don't know that's just an
interesting little tidbit to throw in I
guess and that's it's kind of a mindfuck
yeah like like these ancient gods mating
yeah but like i said george RR martin
obviously is a big fan of cosmic horror
he puts a lot of those elements in there
and it's really exciting to go through
those and pick them out like I said if
you like this video feel free to leave a
like subscribe go to order the green
hand channel subscribe to them I just
wonder for the most part just thank you
for having me this was a ton of fun and
I'm sorry m'lady couldn't be here today
she had some important business to take
care of and yeah just thank you for
having me and hope everyone enjoyed it
yeah it's been a lot of fun and
hopefully next time Mary Ellen can be on
but yeah it's been fun talking about
love craft and these [ __ ] up entities
with you it's always nice to see that
nothing means anything because we're
just the thralls two entities
maneuvering all of our pieces it does
kind of seem like the the overall
direction that this story is going where
like humanity is on the verge of being
crushed between the horses that they
don't understand that are at odds with
each other and humans are just kind of
caught in the middle of it now I take it
a try yeah but I take it a symbolic for
like the game of Thrones is like how the
High Lords battle and the common people
get squashed in the middle I feel it in
the same way these forces in their world
could be battling in a similar way and
just all of humanity is getting crushed
in the middle it's kind of reminding me
of what you just said that George said
this is gonna be me paraphrasing it but
he gave a somewhat lengthy answer about
the game of Thrones
essentially being what everybody is
concentrating up everyone's trying to
vie for power in King's Landing and
they're struggling for it and they're
fighting all these what he called feudal
battles for power and glory he goes
meanwhile on the outskirts of the story
the real threat is looming and everyone
is blind to it because they're not
looking they're paying it to their own
ambitions
you kind of it's uh it gets kind of like
a a microcosm the game of Thrones in the
way that the people are being crushed
beneath the weight of these struggles
it's kind of like almost like a
microcosm of the epic struggle to come
absolutely and it seems like there is no
hope and that's the perfect nihilistic
way to end a Lovecraft podcast we're all
gonna die
how are Margulis L morghulis thanks for
listening guys
you